joining me here before monday night
football at heinz field against the
cleveland browns is a man who uh is
going to the pro football hall of fame
whenever he hangs them up and that is a
large part of the conversation prior to
this huge week 17 game for both teams
joining me here
on monday night football's pregame show
is none other than ben roethlisberger
how you doing big ben i'm doing great
how are you today sir i am doing better
for talking to you man it's been a long
time
and i'm just wondering what's how do you
feel right now it's very that's a very
rare question for me to ask anybody
prior to a game but you know this is a
big game for you and maybe for your
career ben
it is um it's a big game it's it's
any time i've been so blessed the lord
has blessed me in so many ways but to be
able to play in front of the the
greatest fans in sports at heinz field
so anytime you play at heinz field on
monday night against the browns it's
always emotional it's always a lot of
fun and it's exciting and you know you
and i are talking on a day after you
just uh met with the media who hit you
literally right as soon as you hit the
microphone about
this potentially being your last game at
heinz field and i'm wondering what goes
to your head when you hear that question
you know it's like i told them i i never
i never like to speak in guarantees or
definites um but
you know signs are pointing to it being
the last one um
obviously there's still the
outside chance craziness i know some
things have to happen that we could get
another um game at heinz field but but
in terms of regular season games um you
know this is this is probably going to
be it and i'm i'm just um i'm excited
for it and i'm i just want to all i want
to do is win the game that's all that
matters to me
no i know and it's it's kind of bizarre
or awkward that there's so much more
football potentially left for you to
play this year and we're all talking
about the end of maybe your career
and i'm wondering how you work all that
in together my only focus is this game
you know i think the reason it's bigger
and new i mean i've played 18 seasons of
one over 90 football games in heinz
field and so for it to be the potential
last regular season game i think that's
why it's talked about so much but
my my singular focus is going to be
winning this football game um
because uh one because it could be my
little last regular season game but
because it's the browns it's
crunch time we have to win this game um
you know we have to win out to get to
the postseason and even then it's not
guaranteed so um it can be talked about
right now but but my focus is doing
everything i can to win this football
game you know and you're from ohio
obviously you're from miami of ohio and
it seems like you have in your career
saved something special for ohio teams
is that fair to say
well you know you always want to play
well against the teams from your from
your home state uh especially when the
one of them didn't you know kind of
passed on you in the draft it always
sits in the back your head a little bit
i love it so
so
that has been something you
fire yourself up with because they
didn't take you years ago yeah for real
yeah you know there's a lot yeah there's
a lot of teams that obviously like 111
so there's 10 other teams that passed on
me but it you know and so i
any anybody would tell you that i know
that you know brady talks about being
you know wait until the later rounds get
picked and the motivation i mean
everyone finds some sort of motivation
in sport and i think for me it's just
the fact that um you know they they
supposedly needed a quarterback but i'm
i'm from ohio a couple hours like
literally away i went to school in ohio
it you know but i'm listen at the end of
the day i'm very glad i ended up where i
am
of course and you know you've won
championships there and then the
question is is what about this year um
you know for steeler fans to see one
game you guys look like world beaters
and the next day you're getting beat
down uh what to what do you owe that ben
when you think about man
i don't know it's i wish i had the
answer uh you know it's um
it's been a unique season obviously
coming in knowing you've got the hardest
strength of schedule you've got a new
kind of offense new coaches a lot of new
players um you know the guys up front
we've got four rookies up front we've
got a free agent at guard and that's
just at the beginning of the season
right we've we've dealt with a lot of
injuries which a lot of teams have but
i just think that there's been so many
variables that are out of our control
which is what life the nfl is but uh i
don't know that answer i wish i wish i
did so on monday night football as you
are going through the game and obviously
you hope to win it and play more there
this year what what are you gonna do in
the last couple minutes of that game win
or lose do you think ben
yeah i don't know i mean hopefully
hopefully i'm we're winning and i can
sit there and enjoy it and reflect on
um you know the game and the season and
and the games that i've been able to
play there because i've had so many
great memories there i play with so many
great football players in front of like
i said the best fans of sports and
i have been truly blessed um
to be there
when you
are going to hang them up when that
whenever that may be and you say this
probably you've been using some
conditional phrasing um
what is your plan what are you going to
do what do you want to do
ben i am going to do um you know first
and foremost i'm going to become a full
even more full-time husband and dad
that's going to be job number one uh and
then i'm going to do everything i can
um to to try and bring people uh what i
think we're called to do bring people to
christ i think that's a you know my job
on this earth as many people as we can
anything professional would you want to
do media is that something you'd be
interested in calling games anything
like that uh
i'm open for anything i'm open for
anything but i'll probably disappear
more than anything and spend time at
home with the family and coaching i got
three little ones that are right in the
heart of playing sports and doing fun
things so i'll probably be uh more
little league coach than i will college
or football coach okay so how how old
are they right now are you kids ben uh
my oldest just turned nine uh my middle
one my daughter is almost eight and my
youngest boy is five and a half okay so
what sort of coach will you be uh are
you gonna be uh demanding what are you
gonna be gonna be like coward get in
people's faces you can be like tomlin
what are you
what are you going to be more like ben
when you're going to get a little bit of
both
i'm the behind the scenes guy i'm the
one that just gives the looks and and i
probably i remember quite a few coward
stairs you know down the sideline you're
you're 20 or 30 yards away and he sticks
his head on gives you a look um maybe
i'll just just do the looks
okay just you got that down pat i got to
tell you it's kind of funny i was
thinking about this today before you and
i got on the phone ben in the few
minutes i have left with you ben
roethlisberger uh i i thought about the
first time i interviewed you
and it was before the draft and you were
on the set of nfl network in los angeles
you had not yet been drafted and people
were trying to just figure out you know
who you are and what you can be and what
you can do in this career and not many
people had seen you play quite frankly
in college right and now here we are
talking
before what could be the end of your
last game
at heinz field i'll be honest this kind
of feels like an exit interview
right now between the two of us
i don't know if that feels the same
there's been a long time between between
those interviews um right it's been a
lot of great i think it's been a pretty
darn good career for both of us so i
think something we both be proud of
well you know what i i just remember you
know you say you were gonna wear the
number seven and i'm i'm wondering if
things turned out the way that you
you know if i had told you sitting there
in that day on the set of nfl total
access what would happen is this is this
what you would
dreamt of
ben
gosh i mean i think it was always my
goal to win championships um i've been
blessed to win two of them
um and i don't know i mean people ask me
all the time gosh if back then if you
would have said you would have played 18
years would you have believed it and
probably not i mean that's a long
stinking time
um to play this game but like i said i
am i am truly blessed and thankful for
the opportunities that i've been been
given okay and so what do you want fans
of the steelers to know before the end
of
uh this interview before this monday
night football game against the browns
where the season is still on the line
for you
in what could be again as you say is
probably your last game in front of them
in that stadium
you know it's it's it's
i'm gonna give everything i have i
always have um you know whether we're
down by 20 and then with minutes to go
in the game or i'm always going to fight
and give everything i have and so
i'm going to enjoy every moment of this
but but to me there's still work to be
done and i'm going to do everything i
can to get that work done
ben roethlisberger i appreciate the time
um you know you you go big ben and we'll
chat down the line i appreciate the time
here today thanks rich i appreciate it
have a great one you got it that is ben
roethlisberger pro football hall of
famer to be but for monday night a big
time football game in front of the home
folks at heinz field for the pittsburgh
steelers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here